[Musik]
auf der einen seite ist also die
demonstrativ präsenz islamischen
identität auf der anderen seite gibt es
aber auch eine erstarkende gegenbewegung
so etwas wie eine rückbesinnung auf das
besonders ausgeprägte sind sieht bei den
sogenannten identität
sie reklamieren für sich nicht weniger
aus die wahre französische identität und
die ist nicht nur in der politik
[Musik]
erklärt
klar wie mir einsatzdienst den patrioten
die stark leiden gegenwärtig in
frankreich sie werden von allen seiten
angeklickt
musikern aller macht und von der partie
[Applaus]
sie nennen sich lebron sie wollen ihr
frankreich beschützen vor äußeren
einflüssen vor der globalisierung
sie tragen masken wie ihre rebellischen
vorbilder aus der revolutionszeit und zu
plädieren verzögerung wie viele ihrer
anhänger sehen sich diese jungen
menschen als konservative anarchisten
als reaktionäre gebiet
sie teilen gelb tisch und bett und
formen eine lebensgemeinschaft mit 20
erwachsenen und zehn kindern in den
schwarzen bergen in zentral führen
kirche weit weg von den organen meine
traum gesellschaft leben können wie man
will sich versammelt zu dürfen sie man
sich ohne gleich von anderen kritisiert
und verteufelt zu werden und die eigenen
kinder erziehen zu können die man sehen
die kommune ist sehr aktiv mit konzerten
und selbst produzierten videoclips
verbreitet sie alarmstimmung waren vor
dem untergang des christlichen
abendlandes
[Musik]
[Applaus]
egal
[Musik]
man bringt uns und reisende jahr
millionen von leuten her die nicht
franzosen werte die unsere kultur
mehrheitlich verachten
wir sagen wir sind franzosen und wollen
es bleiben wir setzen uns ein für uns
und französischen unseren europäischen
nachbarn die wir je gehört seit fünf
jahren dazu er produziert und vermarktet
die musik auf die dienst und im netz der
erfolgreichste klub bisher mit über
400.000 klicks innerhalb von vier
monaten ist eine kampfansage an die
offizielle multikulti druck
[Musik]
nein
ablehnung von fremden kulturen und
religionen gewürzt mit einer prise
aussteiger romantik und konsum fließt
wie prims orten den ursprung allen übels
in der modernen leistungsgesellschaft
amerikanischer prägung vorgezogen alle
so brave materialistische konsumenten
seien die arbeiten wie die sklaven um
sich zwei wochen ferien pro jahr leisten
so mit den kindern ins titel einfahren
zu können das ist alles so wird es vom
modernen bürger erwartet dass
globalisierung wettbewerb migranten
muslime alles um französisch frankreich
von alldem befreien
das wollen die briten was wohl schon
dach dazu sagen soll
[Musik]